on hopeful bars with Bobby kalila in
taran killam alright this question is
from sorry it's from what just happened
I don't know
Second City bro Derrick second city
owned a is that a filter is that just oh
this is low that's amazing dude did you
ever watch mr. show
I can't we're at the end I know you
could do whatever you want yeah mr. show
wants to show David Cross he can and it
but you don't even need the hand Michael
Clarke Duncan that's awesome that's a
great microphone back today I have a
girlfriend that I've been with for
almost five years and I have three kids
with her recently she started doing
drugs meth and drinking and the next
time I seen her she had hickeys all over
her neck the side of this made me angry
but more than anything I was deeply hurt
should I work it out because we have
children together or should I cut her
off
oh it's out yep read it again it's so
crazy you gotta read it again I have a
girlfriend okay I have a girlfriend that
I had been with for almost five years
five years and have three kids with her
it went fast three kids young recently
she started doing drugs math math and
drinking look [ __ ] this drinking it man
and the next time I seen her she had
hickeys all over her neck either meth
scars or bruton that meth bruises or
she's [ __ ] other guys decided let's
go thick use the side of this right the
side of this made me angry but more than
anything I was deeply hurt should I work
it out because we have children together
or should I cut off all connection with
her I am lost right now
help me your fan now this is called
unhelpful advice right is the Julie hell
I do I mean the real is you got to
contact a lawyer you got have you got to
keep track of everything that's
happening to get a journal get a little
moleskin keep track of when she leaves
do a plug for moleskin let's do sports
they got they got unlined lying
storyboard square yeah and also they
have a little like a ring where you keep
your place yeah it keeps its place right
replace with a most constraint moleskin
it's leather and also it's like what
Edgar Allan Poe used Wow all right
celebrity endorsement right go ahead so
what well you just gotta keep trying you
and you have to contact because you need
to protect the kids yes first and
foremost that's the real reality if
you've been together five you have three
none of them are older than two years to
two and change me so you're saying you
can't work it out you can't whip it out
no I'm not saying that but I'm saying
like order of businesses we need to
protect these children we need to
contact either you know child services
if you need help or or legal
representation or family if you have
that even if it's extended Bobby will
pay to have your children taken to a
family member yeah right travel even if
they're out of state yeah Bobby will pay
I'll take I'll pay for taxes yeah no but
but protect the kids first and foremost
is number one yeah and then begin the
dialogue of is she willing to get help
is she willing to you know address the
certain issues but God if there's three
kids get them I mean I I read an article
this is not to be funny but um this meth
couple they had a newborn and they
boiled it yeah they boiled a baby alive
in their stove okay that's how
delusional and I would add baby Joe I
would have believed that it wasn't meant
to be funny without this to this bit
yeah some things amuck something's
problematic from your short email how
can we possibly know the specifics and
detail and backstory and history of your
relationship but that is not the
priority the priorities not the
relationship it's the children exactly
and [ __ ] your own feelings if you're
hurt that's not the priority right
that's the kids yes yeah it matters a
dangerous drug and we don't know how
much is doing it or what not but also at
the end of the day it's like if she has
a did
drug addiction yeah and she's [ __ ]
around behind your back
she's nickel obviously the season
suddenly she's neglecting the children
right unfit mother
you got to get out of the situation you
gotta protect the kids Yeah right now
the funny answer is this right unhelpful
but recipe for boiled baby
it's like mad [ __ ] is the best [ __ ]
okay because it lasts for a while that's
dry [ __ ] last for a while I don't I'm
going to defend it what it is is this is
that if you okay I was I have the job
that I'm on right I'm sure that I'm all
right where you were my children no yeah
yeah but to make my makeup artist is
this gigantic bear of a man okay and
he's up he's up oh my god sorry
anyway he told me that he was sober and
that he used to do math and then we
talked to because I would I done math
right and as a guy when you're doing
that you jerk off for like 24 hours
watching porn and you can't even come
for you it's not the fact of jerking off
or coming it's a fact that you just want
to keep doing to feel yeah that's what I
mean about meth [ __ ] is that she might
not like it but she's gonna want to keep
doing it you know man
whereas a regular girl that's not on
math a boring one so busy
yeah like I'm just not feeling it let's
focus on you you [ __ ] [ __ ] Messi
Messi poses the greatest guys I'm sorry
[Music]